thank you Amy and good afternoon
everyone
delighted to be here a part of this I'm
gonna pick up right where Amy left off
with this well-known image of Charles
Wilson Peale and his museum because he
probably better than any single person
embodies this overlap of science and art
in the early 19th century and I'm
thinking in particular the way he
displayed his collections in his museum
with these wonderful dioramas a detail
of which were revealed in addition
Ramsey peels study for his father's
self-portrait unfortunately none of the
dioramas survived and we don't have very
good detailed descriptions of them but
we do have some images that were almost
certainly derived from them Amy
mentioned Alexander Wilson earlier and
I'm showing you a plate another plate
from American ornithology the bald eagle
as with many of the other birds in his
book was drawn from a specimen in peels
Museum we think that possibly the
background was based on the diorama
itself so this may be the only surviving
depiction of what one of the peeled
dioramas looked like and it shows ways
in which peels art had a ripple effect
through other artists into the outside
world through publications this very
similar posed eagle by Audubon it may
have come from the same source
obviously Audubon knew the eagle well
and Andrew from his own experience but
he also may have based his work either
on wilson's which would make it a second
generation removed from peels museum or
perhaps on peels diorama itself the
picture was criticized by Georgia Ward
and Charles Waterton and others as being
copied from Wilson and there certainly
are some similarities but I think more
likely they had a common source in the
dioramas Peale's museum was very much a
popular museum he was charging admission
he wanted the public to come and see it
and he had not only mounted specimens
and preserved specimens of all sorts but
even live specimens including a pair of
grizzly bear cubs that were presented to
him
courtesy of Thomas Jefferson but from
zoobel and Pike on one of his Western
expeditions the the Cubs were very cute
at first but then of course they grew up
and became a little bit more unruly and
sadly when one of them escaped peel had
to kill it and then kill its sibling
Titian peel made this drawing of them
after they were mounted for display and
then that picture was in turn copied by
Thomas Doughty
and published and disseminated much more
widely through the cabinet of Natural
History of a popular magazine of the
period so Peale had a huge effect even
to those who didn't have the chance to
actually visit his Museum in
Philadelphia visual imagery was of
course the the language of exchange
internationally during that period and I
show just as an example George Cuvier
his plate of Mastodon teeth so that this
dialogue went both ways across the
Atlantic specimens were at the heart of
these these discussions and the Academy
of Natural Sciences which was founded in
1812 the same time peels museum was was
operating was very much focused on the
specimens and on the scientific exchange
of information and I wanted to
differentiate between the two and you'll
see as they go along as peels museum
actually began to decline from the 1820s
into the 40s when it was finally
dissolved the Academy of Natural
Sciences was moving in the opposite
direction it was growing in numbers and
particularly in the size of its
collections and I show you here just a
range of some of the images the
buildings that the Academy occupied from
its founding in 1812 up until its
current building built in 1876
unfortunately we don't have as many
interior views of these museum buildings
as I wish we did we do have a few
including interestingly the one on the
upper left-hand corners alleged to be
the earliest interior photograph of a
museum existing this is a daguerreotype
which shows among other people Edgar
Allan Poe who was then doing shell
studies at the academy but as you can
see from all of these images even up
until 1900
the museum was pretty much a collection
of specimens it was case after case
after case arranged systematically for
the use of the members although it was
open to the public from 1827 on the
public entertainment was not the primary
mission of the Academy of Natural
Sciences all of that changed quite
abruptly in 1868 not at the instigation
of the Academy but almost by serendipity
the British artist Benjamin Waterhouse
Hawkins who had made his reputation by
creating the first life-size sculptures
of dinosaurs for the Crystal Palace in
London in 1853 came to America
specifically to New York to build a
Paleozoic museum as it was called and
since there were no other experts on
dinosaurs at the time he came to
Philadelphia and spent a good deal of
time at the academy and thanks for all
the help that he received there he
presented the Academy with a fully
articulated dinosaur skeleton the
skeleton had been found by Academy
members and described by Joseph lighty
at the academy Waterhouse Hawkins
thought that it would be good to show it
in its lifelike posture so you see him
there underneath the sculpture on the
left-hand side this is a bit of a
take-off from Charles Wilson Peale zone
erection of the mastodon skeleton in his
museum but surprisingly 1868 this was
the first articulated dinosaur to be
seen in any museum anywhere in the world
and the effect was enormous in the first
year after it was put on display a
hundred thousand visitors came to the
museum to see it and this was at a time
when the museum was only open to the
public for two afternoons a week and it
was closed for the month of August and
July July and August so we're talking
about 40 or 50 days and a hundred
thousand people coming to visit it art
had clearly taken science to a new level
and made it a popular phenomenon the end
of the 19th century the Academy
commissioned the blaschkas
studio the same ones known for having
made the glass flowers at Harvard to
create a series of displays of
invertebrates marine invertebrates in
this case an anemone which were
dazzlingly butyl
and we look at them today as works of
art I'm sure the the curators who
commissioned this work to be done saw
them simply as glass reproductions of
scientific specimens but it's it's an it
raises this interesting overlap of where
as where does art began in science and
in the 20th century the Academy changed
the superficial exterior appearance in
the building
removing the Gothic Revival facade and
replacing it with the sort of Federal
Building as part of the city beautiful
movement and inside dramatic changes
were soon to occur as well from the 18th
from the 1920s through the 60s following
the lead of our younger sister
institution the American Museum in New
York and others the Academy began
developing a series of dioramas and you
see here just a small model by the Jonas
Brothers Studios these projects as we
know well from Steve Quinn's book and
from work Michael Anderson is doing here
at Yale took a great team effort as Amy
refers to it was taxidermists
painters specialists of all kinds to
artificially recreate a lifelike habitat
in three dimensions many of these
dioramas still exist at the academy as
they do here at the Peabody and and at
the American Museum in more recent times
the Academy has focused specifically on
the overlap of science and art by
creating something that we call the art
of Science Gallery and in this space we
do periodic exhibits by creative artists
contemporary artists some of them quite
whimsical in nature others more
seriously scientific one of our speakers
later this afternoon James Prosek will
be exhibiting in the art of Science
Gallery later this year but it's a
wonderful place that brings together the
communities of art and science we also
thought that when we did our
Bicentennial book we wanted the book not
only to reflect the history of the
institution but it's its place in
contemporary America and we commissioned
Rosman Purcell to make photographs from
our collection
now many of you know rosemond's work
she's a boston-based photographer who
work closely with Stephen Jay Gould on a
number of books and many of her own as
well
she's photographed in museums all over
the world but I think she is perhaps the
best of the contemporary photographers
in making scientific specimens of
interest to the art community as well as
to the scientific community
two weeks ago we opened a Bicentennial
exhibit at the Academy which really
brings us full circle it puts specimens
back on display again but I think some
of our founders would be surprised
perhaps even puzzled by the way we've
done this
these were arranged for purely aesthetic
purposes there's no information except
on a separate card about what they are
so as our founders would have arranged
them all taxonomically and had long
explanations of what everything was and
how they related to each other
these were chosen to attract the
interest of the public and and to
reinsert the aesthetic importance of
science into the public dialogue we were
told to keep our presentations very
short so that that's a 200 year history
and didn't in less than 10 minutes but I
invite any of you who would like to come
to Philadelphia and help us continue the
exploration of science and art thank you